yesterday's inauguration was a triumph
of democracy our democracy has never
been more democratic
and we can all revel in democracy
democratizing democracy
if you don't believe me you don't need
to take my word for it you can listen to
the mistress of ceremonies amy klobuchar
who began this
big triumph with an absolute ode to
democracy
now it falls on all of us not just the
two leaders we are inaugurating today
to take up the torch of our democracy
not
as a weapon of political arson but as an
instrument for good we pledge today
never to take our democracy for granted
as we celebrate its remarkable strength
we celebrate its resilience its grit we
celebrate the ordinary people doing
extraordinary things for our nation
the doctors and nurses on the front line
of this pandemic
the officers in the capitol a new
generation
never giving up hope for justice and in
the end
that is america our democracy
a country of so much good and today
on these capital steps and before
this glorious field of flags we
rededicate
ourselves to its cause
thank you there was just one aspect of
the
impeachment that made amy klobuchars and
the rest of them
all of their exultation of democracy
ring a little hollow namely
there weren't any people there the
people
were not permitted to go to the
inauguration
as they were celebrating all the
frontline workers and the ordinary
americans those ordinary americans were
outside
because washington dc looked like
baghdad because there were giant
fences and walls everywhere and the
people were replaced with
little miniature flags all over the mall
so much for democracy i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knoll show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday
uh was from inspecting gadgets who
was reflecting on the new curricula in
schools
he says it's reading writing and racism
in public schools now
that's true we're going to get a whole
lot more of that
if the biden education department picks
go as they are planned if the whole if
the whole administration goes
as it currently looks like it will go
now more than ever
time to protect yourself against people
who don't like you and want to take your
information
and want to use it against you that's
why i love express
vpn i have been talking about expressvpn
on my show for a very long time years in
fact
why have you not gotten a vpn yet ladies
and gentlemen i will tell you this
there has never been a more important
time to protect your digital rights
look at what's happening all around you
that is why i
and thousands of our patriotic listeners
are choosing to
secure our online data by using
expressvpn
did you believe that a vpn is not for
you because you can use the internet
just fine without one no one's coming
after your data right i used to think
that
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every site
you're visiting
and listen some of you if you're
listening to this show maybe you
look at some unsavory sort of content
some content that people won't like you
you know you go on that incognito
window and you start going to crazy
looking sites like dailywire.com
you don't want those isps looking there
take back your privacy at expressvpn.com
michael and get three extra months for
free on a one year package
that is exp or essvpn.com
michael to get three extra months free
expressvpn.com
michael head on over there right now
democracy
triumphed yesterday at an event that the
people were prohibited from attending
amy klobuchar opened this up and she was
the emcee for the day
she did basically as good a job as you
could do as the mc
but if you were paying close attention
and you'll notice that the cameras on
the inauguration
they rarely showed that there weren't
any people there right it was mostly
just on the sort of podium
mostly with the people around joe biden
but mostly even on those first few rows
where there were some scattered people
in the audience but it was unlike any
inauguration we've ever seen
because there were just a handful of
people for the cameras everything else
was empty the people had been replaced
with flags and it wasn't just a choice
of amy klobuchar
to focus on this joe biden himself
made sure to talk about the importance
of democracy and it it's it
was such a bizarre juxtaposition of this
word democracy
without any people there not even joe
who's as slick a politician as they've
ever come
not even he was able to sell it this
is america's day this
is democracy's day a day of history and
hope
of renewal and resolve through a
crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile at this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed democracy has
prevailed
i don't think he could use the word
democracy any more times while still
reading grammatical sentences right he's
packed in as much as possible
makes me think the lady doth protest too
much all these democrats
going on about democracy does that look
like democracy to you
let me just ask you compared to the
trump inauguration in 2016.
lots and lots of people i know there was
some controversy over the crowd sizes
but i think we can all agree
lots and lots of people there versus
this inauguration
without any people which one looks like
democracy prevailed
if you really believe in the cause of
democracy
why would you be so afraid of your own
people that you would lock them out that
you would erect
giant fences with barbed wire
all around washington dc it just doesn't
ring true
you'll notice at the end there biden
says democracy prevailed
and some people think this is just a
typical platitude some empty biden
slogan
it actually gets to the left's view of
democracy
you'll hear them talk about democracy a
lot well they didn't seem to like
democracy very much in 2016
when president trump won and then they
changed a lot of the election integrity
systems in 2020
we'll just leave it right there
democracy prevails according to the left
when they win and democracy fails
according to the left when they lose
right it's it's only ever democracy when
they win when it's not they always say
no it's suppression
it's a voter intimidation it's something
went horribly horribly wrong
and there's actually something to what
they're saying
you know i think that i think it's
important to recognize that's their view
of democracy so
if they lose you know al gore loses well
then that wasn't democracy
or hillary clinton loses well that
wasn't democracy you know it's only only
when they win as a democracy
but prevails you know
is a complex word is it saying democracy
did what democracies do you know it
acted like a democracy or
are they saying democracies gave us a
good government democracy
showed how great democracy is and it's a
sort of subtle distinction
but we all actually look at democracy
in the latter sense of that word right
there first of all we're not a pure
democracy in this country we're not a
direct democracy we're a
republican government which is also
called a democracy
but we we have all of these different
systems in place
to give us our government the electoral
college is a great example of this
you can win the majority of voters
nationwide
and still lose the presidency because we
have this kind of intricate system of
government
there's nothing wonderful about
democracy
in and of itself right if you've got a
vicious people who have absolutely no
virtue who elect
horrible terrible leaders who trample on
everyone's rights well that's not a win
for democracy i mean democracy is acting
as it should
as we would expect it to but it's still
giving us bad government so there's
nothing great in and of itself
and so when biden's saying democracy
prevails i think what he's also saying
is
this is how democracy is supposed to
work and in all fairness
i feel the same way when when these
awful leftists win
i think gosh our democracy is not
functioning as it should if we still had
a virtuous people you know if we still
and
and i know there's all this lamentation
all the time about it used to be better
in the good old days
and a lot of that is just nostalgia
which is history after a few drinks as
my friend father george rutler says
but but there actually is something to
it people used to know more about
our country people used to know more
about our politics about our history
they used to have a clearer view they
used to be better educated than they are
today
they used to be more capable of liberty
than they are today
you can just look at any sort of civic
surveys that are given out there was a
famous one from isi about a dozen years
ago
which showed that graduates of very
prestigious universities
this the graduating seniors knew less
about civics than the incoming freshmen
they actually got more ignorant over
their time
in that in in that educational
environment so that that really does
happen
and i feel the same way when we're
electing these awful people who want to
trample on our national traditions
and who want to upend our system of
government
i think that's bad i think that's a
failure of democracy
you've got to get to the people to have
that prevail
but it was so ironic i mean i don't
think i could ever have the gall
to talk about the failures and triumphs
of democracy to a
crowd of nobody where the people were
not
permitted it was it was a farce of an
inauguration
right down to even the swearing-in so
kamala harris comes up
and she does her swearing in and sonia
sotomayor is the justice who's going to
administer the oath
and they make a big point as they always
do when they introduce sotomayor
of talking about her racial identity and
how she's a woman
this is how she herself sold her
nomination you remember sonia sotomayor
when they said why how are you qualified
to be on the court
you know her resume was a little thinner
than some of the other judges on the
court
and she said well i'm a wise latina
woman you say i don't
i don't see that as a particularly
compelling
uh qualification where i want to hear
about your experience as a judge i want
to hear about your
law school education you know talk about
that just don't talk about this identity
politics
so she gets up there she does the oath
and sonya sotomayor
mispronounces kamala harris's name
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
i kamala davey harris you solemnly swear
so embarrassing
kamala took it in stride and i know
there's there's always been some debate
over what her how her name is pronounced
because it's an unusual name and she's
sort of new to the national political
scene relative to some of these other
people on stage joe biden or even donald
trump
but sotomayor did not even learn how to
pronounce her name i think this does
reflect on both of these people
you know sotomayor uh
she's not she doesn't have a reputation
as the
sharpest bulb on the court okay this was
true at the time of her
of her nomination people said you know
she's no elena kagan
she's no clarence thomas she's no
antonin scalia
are you sure you know in the the left
seem to play identity politics a little
bit as
as she herself did but then kamala
harris too
she's she's so
irrelevant in her own person
remember she was what the first or one
of the first candidates out of the
democratic presidential primary
people didn't like her she she kind of
got in through the back door
of uh into this administration but she
was it's not like
she was the second person standing the
second to last person standing during
the presidential
uh primary but
they they sold her and she sells herself
on identity politics whenever they say
what's your view of politics you've seen
all the interviews we've played them on
the show before
what's your view of politics what's your
ideology what's your philosophy she goes
i'm the daughter of immigrants i was
raised and she talks about all the
identity politics stuff
and so yep even the supreme court
justice administering the oath doesn't
remember her name
because she she is presenting herself as
a stand-in
which which does a disservice to her i
think and it does a disservice
to our politics but there was more force
that went on in this
inauguration than all of that i nearly
fell asleep during it
thankfully i have bowling branch sheets
so you know if i if i did fall asleep at
least i'd get a good night's rest
as i've told many people over the past
couple of days
i've got a brand new bundle of joy at
home
and as a result you might see maybe my
under eye bags are getting a little
worse
obviously you don't sleep that much when
you've got a new baby however
one thing that is helping me sleep
bowling branch they are the best sheets
i've ever used bowling branches
signature sheets
feel so soft and light you will feel
like you were sleeping on a cloud
bowling branch makes the softest organic
sheets on the market
and they get better with every wash
comfort isn't their only standard by the
way
they use 100 sustainable raw materials
and as the first fairtrade certified
manufacturer of linen
you can feel as good about your bowling
brand sheets as they feel against your
skin
you know on a couple of occasions i've
gotten to stay at like really nice
hotels obviously i would never pay for
them myself
but i've gotten to stay there when other
people are paying and the first thing i
notice is the quality of the sheets
they're
so nice you can get that kind of quality
at home every single night go to
bowlingbranch.com
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code michael at checkout
that is bowling branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com
promo code michael obviously bowling
branch top top of the line luxury sheets
you got to go check them out
i really love them but the the most
farcical moment of the
inauguration was the slam poetry portion
i have to tell you i had very low
expectations for
this inauguration and somehow
[Music]
the the reality was even lower because
there was a slam poet
poetry portion of this inauguration the
poet's name
uh of gosh i forget her name amanda
something or other
she's the national youth poet laureate i
didn't know we had one of those and we
actually didn't have one before her they
kind of made up this post
and get to give it to her i will spare
you
the full poem but just take a listen to
the first minute or so
mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhof americans and
the world when day comes we ask
ourselves where can we find
light in this never-ending shade
the loss we carry a sea we must wade
we've
braved the belly of the beast we've
learned that quiet
isn't always peace and the norms and
notions of what
just is isn't always
just is and yet
the dawn is hours before we knew it
somehow we do it somehow we've weathered
and witnessed a nation that
isn't broken but simply unfinished we
the successors of a country and the time
where a skinny black girl descended from
slaves
and raised by a single mother can dream
of becoming president only to find
herself
reciting for one and yes we are
far from polished far from pristine but
that doesn't mean we are
striving to form a union that is perfect
it goes on and on and on
and on it went on for six and a half
minutes
all these rhymes when is justice when
just is is not
justice harold bloom the
famous literary critic uh
referred to slam poetry as the death of
art
and i think he was being charitable
actually in his in his description of it
compare that i don't want to fall into
nostalgia i don't want to say oh it's
always better in the past and now it's
really really bad as though
that were always true no i sometimes the
past was better than the present
sometimes the past was worse than the
present
but but things actually were a little
bit better in the past
jfk's inauguration he had robert frost
one of our nation's
greatest poets come and give the poem
and what's funny is the poem he had
actually prepared for the
for the inauguration blew off the stand
he like couldn't read it that well and
flew away so he ended up reading another
poem of his
take a listen to that poem
the land was hours before we were the
land
she was our land more than a hundred
years before we were her people
she was ours in massachusetts and
virginia
but we were england still colonial
possessing what we still were
unpossessed by
possessed by what we now no more possess
something we were withholding made this
week
until we found out that it was ourselves
we were withholding from our land of
living
and forthwith found salvation and
surrender
such as we were we gave ourselves
outright
the need of gifts was many deeds of war
to the land vaguely realizing westward
but still i'm storied heartless
unenhanced such as she was
such as she would become
has become and i and for this
occasion let me change that to what she
will become that poem
is a very good poem i'm partial i like
robert frost a lot
this is a poem about america about
a traditional understanding of america
the land was ours before we were the
lands
she was ours when we were england still
this is a a view
upholding uh and it's not a perfect view
it's saying that deed of gift was many
deeds of war
it's not saying this is just this
wonderful lala candy land and we've
never had any problems in america
but it's it's taking the side of america
and it's taking the side of good art
it's actually a well-crafted poem the
same cannot be said of that ridiculous
slam poetry
that happened at biden's inauguration
but it's because this has become
a farce our view of our country is
farcical
we hate our country when the left
describes the country it's always about
how terrible it is and bigoted and awful
and all the terrible injustices we've
committed around the world and i'm sorry
and i'm sorry and i'm sorry
and when we when when the left discusses
art
when they perform art there is no beauty
to it it's just ugly
it's ugly art uh when
when the left extols the virtues of
democracy there aren't any people there
it's it's a farce it was a force
of an inauguration and then in comes
president joe biden who actually took
the oath
uh i think it was 12 minutes before he
was supposed to at noon time
which means that for 12 minutes
yesterday we had two presidents
very strange it's sort of like having
two popes which we have at the moment
you know the pope emeritus and then the
pope francis uh joe biden comes up there
and describes after talking about white
supremacy and
all the terrible evil people in america
that he's been talking about for
years and years and years he talks about
the need to unite and i have to tell you
is the scariest part of his whole speech
on this january day
my whole soul is in this bringing
america together
uniting our people united in our nation
and i ask every american to join me in
this cause
uniting to fight the foes we face
anger resentment and hatred extremism
lawlessness violence disease
joblessness and hopelessness with unity
we can do great things important things
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury now
some people are reading this as just
typical biden platitudes again i'd like
to look a little bit deeper
people took time to write this speech
joe biden certainly didn't write this
speech
because joe biden doesn't write any
speeches usually neil kinnick over and
over in ireland will write the speeches
and joe biden will read them
caused him a little trouble back in the
day joe biden is reading a speech that
people took real time
to parse every word he says without
unity there can be no peace my friend
alan estrin pointed out to me yesterday
that can sound a little bit ominous
can't it you remember
during the blm riots when the left was
burning down america
prominent left wingers egged it on
they encouraged it kamala harris said
this won't stop and this better not stop
and it better not stop until the
election maybe even after the election
you remember kamala harris bailed out
the rioters the people who became
violent
biden's staffers biden himself didn't
bail out the writers but by the staffers
were promoting that same fundraiser to
bail out the rioters and he's saying
we need unity all you neo-nazis all you
white supremacists we need unity
all you 70 million evil deplorable
terrible bitter clinging bible-thumping
americans
we need unity and without unity
there can be no peace was that saying
that the
evil rotten right-wingers are not going
to bring peace
or is it saying shape up fellas
or we are not going to give you peace
well who's committed more political
violence in the last year
the last several years the left i mean
it's not even close i know we keep
focusing on the capital riot
as though this were you know the single
worst event in american history
certainly certainly was a pretty ugly
event but
it wasn't even close to the blm riots
which went on for months and destroyed
many more lives
literally killed more people and
destroyed many more businesses and many
more livelihoods
and it wasn't anything compared to
the political violence we've seen from
maxine waters or hillary clinton there's
people who say get up in
people's faces cory booker said get up
in the faces of some congressman
not good you know when i when i think
about all of this when i
when i listen to joe biden's sort of
ominous
speech when i listen to the farcical
kind of
uh poetry that was read well especially
when i listened to that poem i thought
i thought of an ezra pound poem which is
the thought of what america could be if
the classics had a wide circulation
troubles my sleep well
you can get the classics through great
courses i love great courses
a wonderful way to go back to the wisdom
of the ages at this moment when
everything is so fraught and tense
they're wonderful courses i mean you can
get great courses on sort of very
practical things how to play guitar that
sort of thing or you can get courses
that are
about like medieval history those are
the ones that i'm more interested in
2020 was full of unique challenges that
made us
change our whole way of life but with
each challenge
we learned to survive thrive and strive
to be better
we do not know what 2021 will bring not
looking great so far
but hopefully it'll be better the way i
can promise you it'll be better is with
the great courses plus we can make this
our year by continuing to learn with
purpose
with the great courses plus the
opportunities to learn are endless
get unlimited access to stream thousands
of video and audio courses
from top experts in their fields like
how to build a better financial plan
how to control stress and make it work
for you how to even play guitar like a
pro and so those are the practical kind
of courses the ones i really like
are the courses about the battle of
hastings the courses about the middle
ages i mean
really cool scholarly stuff that you can
get right on your tv you can get it on
your phone you can start it on your
phone then you can continue it on your
tv
really really great stuff what is your
purpose this year what new things are
you going to learn sign up
for the great courses plus and find out
go to the thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles you'll get an entire month of
unlimited access for free
you do not want to pass this up go to
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles that is thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles go check them out they're a
wonderful way to
to to begin
your process of re-educating yourself uh
in this very hollow time of of education
and national unity
the main aspect of this inauguration
that
struck out to me it was so short
it was a little an hour and change it
was like an hour and
15 minutes maybe you think they would
have wanted to go on longer and longer
obviously joe biden needed a nap
you know i'm right now in the hospital
still with my newborn child and
uh i think joe biden probably takes more
naps than
the little baby knowles does so maybe
that's part of it that's why on the
campaign trail he would never be out and
about for
for very long but also i think they just
felt they had to go out they give a
little show
but there were no people there it was it
was perfunctory they had to go out and
give a show and yeah unity in america
and yeah america's great
okay we're going to go in now and start
undoing the entire trump administration
we're going to start fundamentally
transforming america yet again
now more than ever we want a little
safety we want a little security you got
to go check out ring
so much happens at our front doors and
that is one thing that is definitely not
changing these days
it has never been more important to be
able to see who is there
and what is happening that is why it is
the perfect time to upgrade your
doorstep
with a ring video doorbell with ring you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door
from anywhere right on your phone so you
will never miss a visitor
with motion detection you'll even get
notified if they don't ring the doorbell
it really just gives you peace of mind i
travel a fair bit
and i'm i'm thinking look sweet little
lisa she's a pretty
resourceful young gal and i've got my
sweet little bundle of joy at home now
too
i'm really pleased that my wife can see
who is at the front door
even without opening that door maybe
it's a delivery man maybe it's the pizza
guy maybe it's the in-laws i don't in
that case obviously you want to stay
perfectly still very very quiet
right now you can get a special offer on
the ring welcome kid at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 in chime pro the perfect way to
upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience go to
ring.com knowles ring.com slash
knowles k-w-l-e-s you know how much i
love ring makes me feel super duper safe
especially now that i got this little
one who has arrived
and if you haven't heard about it yet
daily wire is now in the entertainment
game
last week we released our first film run
hide fight
exclusively for daily wire members the
left is so angry about this the critics
gave it like a
zero percent on rotten tomatoes um
however
the people gave it like a 98 on rotten
tomatoes which is how you know you're
looking at a good
movie the hollywood reporter says what's
most notable about kyle rankin's slick
and compulsively watchable genre entry
run hide fight
is the utter shallowness of its
psychological perspective
the the armchair auteur says while i
found this film considerably less
distasteful than i imagined it's still
being released by some despicable people
and the film's underlying themes are
gross because
of these reviews we want to encourage
all of you to go watch it because
we just love we're going to change the
tumblr it's now going to say
leftist hollywood critics tears and
we're going to just guzzle them up every
day
if you haven't seen it head on over to
daily wire use promo code rhf to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 off we'll be
right back with a lot more
one aspect of the inauguration more than
the others
uh i think gave us a preview of the
biden administration
which is after the hour hour minute
ceremony
up on the podium with the speakers biden
goes over
to the lincoln memorial and they get a
nice photo op of joe biden standing
paying his homage to the lincoln
memorial our sort of pagan
temple to civic religion which which is
i'm not i'm not even using that as a
kind of a joke or a mockery that is the
purpose of the lincoln memorial is to be
a temple
to the american civic religion and
that's why lincoln's sitting there like
zeus
and it's a greco-roman temple so biden
goes in there pays his respects there's
a cello playing
one aspect of it though that you can't
help but notice is
joe biden just issues a mandate that on
federal lands
you have to wear a mask right this is
part of his big push he wants everyone
to wear masks all the time
in america and then after the masks
after 100 days presumably he's going to
say okay you can take your masks off we
beat the virus it's all thanks to me
not thanks to trump by the way who
handled the virus marvelously
got a vaccine out in six months uh
really did a great job and did much
better than the governors no
biden's going to take credit however on
federal land
at the lincoln memorial joe biden not
wearing a mask
that is that is going to be
the hallmark i think of the biden
administration is there going to be
rules and mandates
for thee but not for me
they're going to be rules that all the
deplorable bitter clingers have to play
by
but that the elites will not play by you
know
angelo codevilla who's a claremont
institute
fellow really brilliant writer he had a
piece in the american greatness
where he described the kind of cycle of
regimes and how america
more and more resembles an oligarchy
that the idea of the cycle of regimes is
that you have
democracy and then it it can decay into
oligarchy and then oligarchy
can transform into monarchy and then
monarchy can be overturned and turned
into democracy and this is kind of a
classical cycle of regimes
looking up at the people extolling the
virtues of democracy yesterday
it looks a lot like an oligarchy it does
you see all the same familiar faces and
you don't see very many
representatives of the people there and
you see all these elites playing by one
set of rules
that they that they then voiced another
set of rules on the people
that we're going to get a whole lot more
of that and nobody
nobody is going to hold biden and
company
to account we had our first press
briefing yesterday you remember what the
press was like
to sarah sanders or to kayleigh
mcinerney
or to sean spicer for that matter during
the trump administration it was
vile i mean it was really unseemly even
by the standards of the press
yesterday it was a little bit of a
different tone with
all that's going on the press decides to
ask
jen saki i don't know how to pronounce
her name it's p-s-a-k-i
is it sake is the piece i'll say the p
assignment gen saki they ask her
the most important questions on
everybody's mind and you know she thinks
they're really brilliant she gives them
a very serious answer
on a lighter note will he keep donald
trump's air force one color scheme
change
this is such a good question i have not
had the opportunity to dig into that
today
given the number of executive actions
orders the inauguration
a few things happening um i will venture
to get you an answer on that and maybe
we can talk about it in here tomorrow
that is such a good question because
we're all wondering now that
joe biden is issuing all these executive
orders he ditches his inauguration as
quickly as he possibly can so he can get
back to the business of
governing and implementing his not even
i'm not even saying joe biden himself is
some personal
radical leftist he's just nothing he's a
vessel he's a vessel for the liberal
establishment and the entire liberal
establishment has gone
radically quite left so he's just there
sign and sign and signing executive
orders and uh
yeah so jen hasn't been able to get that
answer but you know it's a great
question
we'll get to it tomorrow okay guys now
we're all gonna head over and have
drinks right
because we're all really good friends
because we're all exactly the same
because the press and the press
secretary and the administration
and big technology and every it's all
part of the same thing it's all part of
the liberal establishment there was one
almost kind of tough question not really
a tough question but they pushed a
little bit
i said you know joe biden is making it
a priority number one to undo
most of president trump's pro-life
accomplishments
why why is that isn't that kind of weird
for that to be priority number one
how can you can you please comment jen
sackey on
uh joe biden's bizarre obsession with
killing all these babies two big
concerns for pro-life
american the height amendment which of
course
keeps tax payer dollars as you know from
paying for abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what are president what is president
biden planning on doing in those two
items right now
uh well i think we'll have more to say
on the mexico city policy in the coming
days
but i will just take the opportunity to
remind all of you
that he is a devout catholic and
somebody who attends church regularly
he started his day attending church with
his family this morning um
but i don't have anything more for you
on that
what an answer and joe biden leaned into
this a little bit during his
inauguration he invoked saint augustine
outrageously he invoked saint augustine
and so
he he's been talking about how he's so
is wonderful devout catholic
joe biden it goes without saying is not
a devout catholic
joe biden is in a state of grave mortal
sin
because he is in public office and he is
supporting abortion
and more than that he is forcing
taxpayers he's trying to force taxpayers
to fund abortion and to subsidize
abortion
this is a grave mortal sin this is why
he was denied the eucharist at a mass i
believe
in north carolina though other more
politicized
members of the episcopacy have have let
him get away with it
joe biden is not only committing that
sin he's committing the sin of scandal
because
you've got this very high profile
catholic who is violating
a very important teaching of the church
now you might say michael look there are
some people who are conservative
catholics who
who violate other teachings of the
church and usually they leave it kind of
vague like that but they'll try to say
well you know they don't give enough
money to the poor
you say well actually conservatives
donate more money to charity than
liberals do
say well no but their public policy it's
not totally in line with catholic social
teaching well
often it's pretty close but putting all
of that aside
we must remember life is not just one
issue among many it's not like abortion
and tax policy are on the same level
life is the fundamental right without
which
you can't have any of the other rights
and it is a grave grave sin
for joe biden to be supporting these
policies
and for him to be doing so publicly and
for him to be blasphemously invoking his
religion
to do so that is a grave grave grave
mortal sin
and that's all we're going to hear from
gensake you notice she didn't answer the
question
she'd say hey you know pro-life
americans are worried that your lunatic
boss is trying to make all of them fund
abortions overseas
and it not only in america but overseas
too
and she says well he's a devout catholic
he goes to church does he now okay
i hope he's not receiving the eucharist
at church because that's a sin too
if you're in the state that joe biden is
very obviously in
there's not going to be any pushback
that's just we are going to be gas-lit
and gas-lit
and gas-lit and it is very sad on this
issue of the abortion policies and other
policies
joe biden is rolling back a great many
of president trump's accomplishments
he's doing that because many of those
accomplishments were made through
executive order
and so joe biden comes in with his
executive orders and he undoes them
i am not as opposed to executive orders
as
many of my conservative friends as many
people on the right you'll hear the
right complaining about executive orders
all the time
i think there's actually a good argument
for executive orders namely
the legislature doesn't want to
legislate ever even when they've got
unified government they don't want to
legislate because they don't want to go
on the record because they're cowards
so obviously there's an incentive there
for the the executive branch wants to do
anything they got to do it through eos
but also also our government is not run
in the way that the constitution
describes it has
grown and changed over time specifically
during the 20th century
such that now it's not really the
legislature that makes the laws it's the
administrative state it's the federal
bureaucracies is
making most of the laws that actually
affect our lives
and so if it's the executive agencies
that are actually passing the laws then
the most direct way
to influence the laws is through
executive orders that's the only way you
even have a chance at doing it
and the trouble with this is when the
left writes an executive order
it goes into effect because the
bureaucracy is left-wing
when a conservative writes an executive
order it doesn't go into effect
because the the bureaucracy is left-wing
so you're already at a disadvantage
and it does remind you if you can get
some legislative achievements that can
be very very helpful
because if you govern through executive
order then the minute you got a new
administration the executive order
the executive orders will be overturned
the biden administration according to
nbc
is going to roll back title 10 funding
for planned parenthood
so donald trump went in and he did
defund planned parenthood partially i
think it was only
only a fraction you know of planned
parenthood's funding but it was still
pretty good he took away federal funding
through title 10 biden's going to bring
that back
biden is going to expand taxpayer-funded
abortion abroad he's going to eliminate
protections for religious employers
who don't want to pay for employees
contraceptives and abort of fashion
drugs
and there's going to be more debate over
what constitutes an abortion drug
the left is going to say that that plan
b is not an abortion drug
because it doesn't always result in
abortion sometimes it can result in
abortion
they're going to say that it's not
abortion because it stops the fertilized
egg from implanting in the uterus and
conservatives are going to say rightly
that is abortion because life begins a
conception not an implantation uh biden
is going to roll back protections
for the height amendment right which
protects americans
from directly paying for abortion even
though money is fungible so we already
do
pay for abortion all of this to say
i hope that the quote-unquote
evangelicals for biden are happy there
are some prominent people
in this country who used to call
themselves conservatives and they still
sort of pretend to call themselves
conservative
who say that they're devout christians
who supported joe biden last cycle
and now this is on their hands this they
they are guilty of enabling this
life is not one issue among many life is
the paramount
right from which the other rights flow
and and they bear some responsibility
for this
you know we're told joe biden's a
moderate he's a totally moderate guy
this bloodthirsty lunatic went for
abortion right away
day one the inauguration was barely over
and he starts going for this stuff
a hint of the radicalism we're going to
see it's very
unfortunate to see so many trump
accomplishments rolled back you know the
other day during president trump's
farewell speech which i thought was a
very good speech
he described his legacy and it gave me a
little happiness a little bit of hope
when he described it as a result of our
bold diplomacy and principled realism
we achieved a series of historic peace
deals in the middle east
nobody believed it could happen the
abraham accords
opened the doors to a future of peace
and harmony
not violence and bloodshed it is the
dawn of a new middle east
and we are bringing our soldiers home i
am especially proud to be the first
president in decades
who has started no new wars
above all we have reasserted the sacred
idea
that in america the government answers
to
the people our guiding light our north
star
our unwavering conviction has been that
we are here to serve the noble
everyday citizens of america our
allegiance is not to the special
interests corporations or global
entities
it's to our children our citizens and to
our nation itself
i love that i loved every part of that
that was a wonderful description
and unfortunately a lot of it's going to
be undone i hope some of the peace deals
last
but the trouble is that biden is very
likely going to re-enter the the
awful iran deal and that's probably
going to destabilize the region further
joe biden utterly utterly beholden to
the foreign policy establishment which
is probably going to be want to be more
provocative in the middle east
president trump one of his great
accomplishments was sort of routing the
foreign policy establishment
that probably gone the abortion policy
obviously gone
uh many many many of the executive
orders going to be gone
a lot of that is about to be undone
even down to the white house website i i
was looking yesterday
online sort of sitting in the hospital
room with my newborn child
let's see is it all crazy already
on the white house website they've
already gotten rid of the 1776
commission
which was an answer to the 1619 project
6019 project says america's evil and
awful and terrible
trump comes in and says we need a 1776
commission biden already got rid of that
he said we need to
we need to keep people thinking america
is rotten and terrible first thing
second thing on the white house website
you now
have to insert your pronouns when you
contact the white house you can say
she her he him they them other you can
say that you prefer not to share your
pronouns
still a choice on the list they don't
unfortunately have she him
what if in the nominative i want to be a
woman but in the accusative i want to be
a man they don't
permit that hopefully equality will
prevail and we'll get more pronouns
when we're all told biden's a moderate
he's going to unify the country joe
biden on the white house website on day
one
is buying into the most radical sexual
ideology we've ever seen
gender ideology buckle up folks and i
hope you have nothing but scorn
for the fake conservatives who endorsed
this guy
beyond the website joe biden
is showing you what his administration
is going to look like through subtle
things you remember you remember this
in the early days of the trump
administration there was a report that
went out that donald trump removed a
bust of martin luther king from the oval
office
and this was a evidence of his racism
first of all i
i don't know i like martin luther king i
guess as much as the next guy but
you know there are a lot of great
americans i don't know if if one were to
move the martin luther king bust from
the oval office to some other room in
the white house i don't think that would
be
the crime of the century and by the way
trump didn't even move the bus to martin
luther king was completely fake news
but these little things how you
rearrange the oval office it can tell
you actually a lot about the direction
of the presidency
so president trump had this portrait of
andrew jackson hanging in the oval
office and this was seen to be
significant
because jackson was something of a
populist right he deferred to the people
not to the kind of crooked
established elite it's not that elites
always have to be crooked
but sometimes they are and right now it
certainly seems they are so
so he had this picture of jackson joe
biden got rid of that
jackson portrait he replaced it with
benjamin franklin
i suspect some of this has to do with
the fact that benjamin franklin was the
oldest founding father
and joe biden is about 500 years older
than benjamin franklin
there are a lot of ways to read it you
know you could read it one that way
i think the left could read this as
evidence
of their thesis that the parties
switched you know that the left will say
this a lot they'll say
you know yeah the democrats used to be
bad and they defended slavery and jim
crow and all that stuff but then the
party switched one day
they all the democrats said you're going
to be republican we're going to be
republicans now and you republicans
you're going to be democrats now
and it doesn't really make a lot of
sense but
andrew jackson's the founder of the
democratic party
so the idea that the republican
president would embrace him
and the democratic president would shun
him is some evidence
that the party's switched and my take on
this is not to say it's
just completely preposterous it's
preposterous to think that the party
switched that just didn't happen
but it's not preposterous to say that
parties have changed over time of course
parties are going to change over time
and as different political circumstances
change they're going to focus more on
one issue or another issue that might
change their views on something so
sure that happens i think the deeper
reading here though
is just to focus on the democratic party
and show that the democratic president
in 2021
is shunning the founder of the
democratic party
for the same reason that he's shunning
the 1776 commission
and supporting the 1619 project because
for the left the past always has to be
bad
you have to always kill your father it's
it's a patricidal sort of ideology you
always have to go back and kill your
forefathers the people who came before
you the people who gave you your country
you know the conservative view of the
country is
yeah our forefathers weren't perfect
we're not perfect either right it's a
fallen world and we have a broken human
nature
but we're so grateful to our forefathers
for giving us this great inheritance
of this wonderful country and we're
gonna you know work to do our part to
preserve it for our children
it would be so wonderful if we could do
as great a job as they did thank you so
much we're standing on the shoulders of
giants and
and some people think we're flying but
we know we're not we know we're on the
shoulders of giants
and for the left they say no we're so
much better
we in the present are so much better
than them they were evil they were
racist they were bigoted
and we are pure as the freshly newly
driven snow
and they've got to destroy not not only
the forebears that they don't identify
with but even
the founder of their own party notice
jack you know the choice to replace him
with franklin is interesting
also because franklin was never
president right franklin was just this
wonderful eccentric american brilliant
figure
who was an inventor and he was a
founding father and
but he never had to be really on the
record
as a president of the united states
there's no real record of of
national leadership that he has to
answer for
it's a way of sort of evading that kind
of historical responsibility
i think it tells you a lot i i don't
think i'm you know reading too deeply
into these things
all of especially on day one what the
president start to do
really really matters and all the signs
we got from that force of an
inauguration
are really really bad now
even though we're told we're going to
get unity and peace and it's wonderful
and joe's going to bring the temperature
down it seems like they're ramping the
temperature up they were ramping up
censorship of conservatives even before
the inauguration
even while president trump was still in
office now
there were calls not just to censor the
president
or i'm sorry the former president donald
trump but there are calls to censor
conservatives generally on cnn you have
a cnn guest coming on saying
enough is enough we have got to kick
these guys out of the public sphere
we have to turn down the capability of
these conservative influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example
that have a larger data a larger
audience than daytime cnn
and they are extremely radical and
pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes
in particular to think about whether or
not they want to be effectively cable
networks for disinformation
and then we're gonna have to figure out
the oann and newsmax problem you know
that
these companies have freedom of speech
but i'm not sure we need
verizon at t comcast and such to be
bringing them into tens of millions of
homes
this is you know allowing people to seek
out information if they really want to
but not
pushing it into their faces i think is
where we're gonna have to go here
we're gonna have to shut down
conservative outlets first of all buddy
i don't know what this guy's name is but
say my name if you're gonna talk about
me like that say my name if you're going
to say
there are some people on youtube who you
know generally have a bigger audience
than
daytime cnn say my name you coward if
you want to kick me off
you look me in the eye when you try to
do it but even beyond that he's not even
just saying let's kick off the youtube
guys
he's saying let's kick off people in oan
and newsmax
oan and newsmax two tv stations that i
go on a fair bit
it's not like they're channel five right
it's not like they're on
your basic television on network
television they're kind of higher up in
the
cable channels you you have to go there
you have to request this kind of stuff
to see and he's saying now and no it's
too much
we the way he's phrasing it is we don't
want to shove
that kind of right-wing television in
their face it's not being shoved in
their face you have to go you have to
sign up for it you got to go
up to the channel right and what he's
really saying is no we can't even give
people the option
the youtube look youtube is not just
shoving it in your face youtube you have
to go you subscribe to a channel you
search for it
say no people can't have that option
we need peace we need unity and if you
don't have unity you're not going to
have peace
if you don't have people you don't have
a democracy buddy lots of contradictions
in this inauguration
unfortunately lots to dread from joe
biden
if i weren't a conservative and i didn't
have a deep abiding faith that this
world is broken
and a deep and abiding hope in the in
the world here to come
i i would not be feeling good after that
inauguration but hope springs eternal
i'm michael moses the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show president biden gives
his inaugural address
and unleashes his early policies so is
it all about unity or is it about
compliance
that's today on the bench shapiro give
it a listen